the war on history ongoing for years now  has two phases the first phase is to  demonize all of our cultures historical  heroes turn them into uh cartoon  villains basically downplay their  successes and virtues while emphasizing  their shortcomings and shortcomings and  if they did not have enough shortcomings  to emphasize then simply invent evil  deeds that they didn't actually commit  uh and this is easy enough to do it's  not like they're around to defend  themselves from the slander so you could  say whatever you want about them then  tear down their statues take their names  off of buildings turn them into sources  of national shame whereas before they  were sources of national pride the left  has a word actually for this first phase  it's problematize which is to make a  problem out of something or someone that  was not a problem before